interbancaire mondial
considéré comme larmes financière ultime
pour sanctionner la russie le système
swift fondée en 1973 est basé en
belgique
un rouage discret mais devenu essentiel
dans les échanges bancaires
internationaux organisés sous forme de
coopérative de banque la société est
notamment à l'origine du code bic qui
permet d'identifier une banque via un
code unique en quelques chiffres swiss
re group quelques onze mille
organisations bancaires et
infrastructures de marché pour 40
millions de transactions quotidiennes
dans plus de 200 pays et territoires
alors exclure la russie du système c'est
lui interdire de recevoir ou d'émettre
des paiements via ce canal avec un
possible effet dévastateur sur son
économie les chancelleries occidentales
n'écarte plus scénario en dernier
recours nous allons frapper les banques
russes nous voulons isoler
financièrement la russie nous voulons
couper tous les liens entre la russie et
le système financier mondial nous allons
asséché les financements de l'économie
russe mais c'est aussi l'économie
européenne qui pourrait en pâtir la
russie étant le cinquième partenaire
commercial de l'union elle lui fournit
aujourd'hui 40% de son gaz
l'autre crainte chez les occidentaux
celle de voir moscou se doter à terme de
son propre réseau interbancaire le
problème auquel lui ai fait face et
aussi les états unis et que la russie
développe son propre système
interbancaire parallèle si vous excluez
la russie du swift elle va simplement
développer davantage le sien avec la
chine en concurrence avec le système
swift
jusqu'ici seul l'iran frappé par une
série de sanctions américaines en 2019 a
vu certaines de ces banques suspendu du
réseau la république islamique avait
même été déconnecté du swift de 2012 à